تطورات عده شهيده حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قال الجيش الاوكراني ان 10 مدنيين
قتلوا في قصف الروسي المكثف على مقاطعه
خرسون وان قوته صدت محاولات تقدم للقوات
الروسيه في مقاطعه دونيسكو ولوغازي شرقيه
البلاد من جهتها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه توجيها ضربتا باسلحه عاليه الدقه
في مقاطعه خاركيف شماليه اوكرانيا وانها
صدقت محاولات هجوم القوات الاوكرانيه في
زافيروجيا ولوجانزك ودونيسيا نتابع الوضع
الميداني في اوكرانيا مع مراسلاتنا في
دنيا السلام خضر ومراسلنا في ميكو لايف
تامر الصمادي تامر اطلعنا على الوضع
وحصيله القصف الروسي على المناطق
نعم جلال بالفعل حل التو عندنا من خيرسون
نستطيع القول بان القصف والقصف المضاد على
اشد بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
تحديدا عند ضفتين نهر الذي يفصل خيرسون
الى جزئين القصف لا يتوقف وتحديدا قصف
المدينه السلطات الاوكرانيه تحدثت خلال
الساعات الماضيه عن ان الساعات الاخيره
عدد
او عدد ما تم قصفه من مناطق يتجاوز 49
منطقه في غير سون من قبل القوات الروسيه
وفي المقابل هنالك قصف تنفذه القوات
الاوكرانيه بالمدفعيه على القوات الروسيه
التي انسحبت من غير سون قبل اسبوعين من
الان
وتمركزت عند الضفه اليمنى من نهر دنيبر
هذه القوات تتعرض لقصف اوكراني كما تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه هنالك خسائر في العتاد
والارواح وفقا للروايه الاوكرانيه لقياده
عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه خلال الساعه
الاخيره دعت السلطات السكان الى همم مره
اخرى وهذا وهذه دعوه متكرره الى الاختباء
بالملاجئ في خيرسون ودعتهم ايضا الى
الهجره التوعيه النزوح الطوعي من خيرسون
الى همم المقاطعات الاخرى تحديدا في وسط
اوكرانيا الى العاصمه وتحديدا العاصمه
كياب والى غرب اوكرانيا التي
تضررت بشكل اقل من الحرب ال- الهجره
النسوح متواصله في الحقيقه وقد رصدنا ذلك
بشكل واضح خلال ساعات الماضيه ويوم امس
واول من امس هنالك هجره واضحه للمدنيين من
خيرسون تحدثت السلطات صباح على هذا اليوم
عن مقتل 10 مدنيين واصابه العشرات نتيجه
القصف الروسي المتواصل تقول بان القوات
الروسيه تكثف من تواجدها على الضفه الاخرى
كما كنا في البدايه بالنهار دنيبر
التطورات ايضا على الصعيد الانساني غايه
في السوق في خرسان وهو ما رصدناه ايضا من
الانقطاع للتيار الكهربائي للماء لعدم
توفر الاغذيه لعدم توفر مقومات الحياه من
يعني تفاصيل متعلقه بالاتصالات بشبكه
الاتصالات بشبكه الانترنت كل شيء مقطوع في
خيرسون هذا الامر ايضا ينسحب على مقاطعاته
اخرى في الجنوب هنا في منكولاي كان هنالك
قصف مكثف للقوات الروسيه على منطقه اشتوكه
وتحديدا على تجمعات المياه قطعت المياه
منذ صباح هذا اليوم عن اغلب مناطق
المقاطعه المدينه ميكولايف تقول السلطات
بانها تعمل على اصلاح هذه الاضرار لكنها
تواجه قصف متواصل كما تقول من قبل القوات
الروسيه وتطورات بالتاكيد نهايه فيزا في
القصف لا يتوقف فوق السلطات الاوكرانيه من
قبل القوات الروسيه صحيح صحيح في المقابل
سلام ايضا القوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها
تقصف المناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه او حتى همم
الانفصاليون لها ماذا تخبرين بهذا الصباح
جلال واضح ان خط الجبهه وخط التماس
المباشر بين القوات الروسيه والقوات
المواليه لها من جهه والقوات الاوكرانيه
في دانيتس هو خط المتحرك اليوم هناك قصف
متبادل بين الجانبين لاحظنا اليوم او ابرز
ما جرى اليوم هو اعلان الرئيس الموالي
لروسيا هنا في دانياتك ان القوات الروسيه
تحقق تقدم على عده محاور كلام الرئيس
الموالي بروسيا ترافق مع استهداف يمكن ان
نقول بانه مكثف خاصه في ساعات الصباح وظهر
اليوم على بعض الاحياء هنا في مدينه دانيت
اسفر عن مقتل شخصين على الاقل في دانياتك
وفي خرسان اعلنت السلطات المواليه لروسيا
ان السته اشخاص من المدنيين قتلوا بقصف
مدفعيا شنته القوات الاوكرانيه هذه
التطورات جميعها ترفقت مع تحضير السلطات
المحليه هنا في دانيات السكان
ضروره اخذ الحيطه والحذر عند التنقل في
المدينه نتيجه استمرار القصف الصادر بشكل
خاص من منطقه الضيافكا التي تتمركز فيها
القوات الاوكرانيه تبعد عن وسط مدينه
دنيتك عن المكان الذي نقف فيه قرابه 12
كلم وهذا هي او هذه هي النقطه التي تستهدف
مدينه دنياسكو بعض الاحياء عند اطرافها
خاصه بمناطق القتال وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
جلال كانت قد قالت اليوم انها صدت محاولات
تقدم عند في محور لوغانسكو اجبرت القوات
الاوكرانيه على التراجع وتحدث وقال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع اليوم ايضا
الدفاع الروسيه طبعا
ان ضربات جويه وصفها بالدقيقه نفذتها
القوات الجويه الروسيه واستهدفت ثلاث
مواقع مؤقته وصفها بالمؤقته لمن سماهم
المرتزقه البولنديين في منطقه خاركيف
اسفلت عن مقتل نحو 200 من هؤلاء وجنوب
دونيت هناك استهداف مماثل ايضا بحسب
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وايضا
للفيلق الاجنبي ما ادى الى مقتل حوالي 100
جندي ايضا يحملون الجنسيه الفنديه بجميع
الاحوال جلال ابرز ما قاله ايجور في
المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه نستمع اليه
في هذه الصوتيه
ياسر
3 نقاط من الانتشار المؤقت للمرتزقه
البولنديين في قريه فليكوتور بمنطقه
خاركييف وفي 06
اكثر من 100 مرتزق من الفيلق الاجنبي
بالاضافه الى تدمير دبابتين ومركبتين
قتاليتين ومصفحتين وفي محور كوبيانز جنه
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هجومين في
منطقه
للهجومين مما ادى الى مقتل النحو 30 جنديا
اوكرانيا وتدمير ثلاث مركبات
شكرا لكم